2300 postes sur 21 mille en france d'ici
trois ans michelin entend supprimer plus
de 10 % de ses emplois
mais pas de départ contraint selon la
direction pas de fermeture d'usiné
aucun départ contraint nous anticipons
environ 60% de mesures de préretraite et
40% de départs volontaires dans le cadre
de rupture conventionnelle collective
face à la concurrence des pneus à prix
cassés michelin tente de rebondir
objectif investir dans des secteurs
d'avenir hydrogène impression 3d ou
encore recyclage des déchets plastiques
d'ici à 2030
l'entreprise souhaite que 30% de son
chiffre d'affaires soit réalisé en
dehors de l'industrie du pneu des
activités grâce auquel le fabricant
français promet de recréer autant
d'emplois qu'il en aura supprimé mais
l'activité initiale du groupe concerne
15 sites en france
l'annnonce de suppressions de postes
inquiète les syndicats
il y aura des négociations mais c'est
comme un plan de sauvegarde de l'emploi
sans licenciement la première année il y
aura des volontaires mais après on
connaît la méthode michelin pour en
fabriquer ce seront des volontaires par
dépit de son côté le gouvernement promet
d'être attentif aux promesses de
michelin avec les représentants du
personnel
nous serons particulièrement vigilants à
ce que michelin respecte ses engagements
depuis 2010 est l'entreprise a déjà
supprimé 1500 postes dans le cadre de sa
réorganisation notamment au siège
historique de clermont ferrand et aux
états unis
michelin dit avoir retardé cette
nouvelle réduction d'effectifs à cause
de la crise sanitaire
depuis le début de la pandémie de covile
19 et le premier confinement en france
les annonces de plans sociaux et de
fermetures de sites industriels se
multiplient renault auchan bridgestone
airbus bénéteau camaïeu ou encore
nextradiotv
aucun secteur ne semble épargné